A streak of warm blood splattered across the
snow.
Steam rose off it as it fizzled into the ice
crystals below.
The severed leg it’d just spurted from lay
twitching only a few inches away, torn clean
off at the hip like a broken Barbie doll.
I think it might’ve belonged to Arthur.
It wasn’t the first time I’d seen limbs
cut off.
Hell, I’ve cut a few off myself in my time.
Don’t worry, I’m not a serial killer - Just
a med student.
We all were.
I couldn’t say the same for the nightmare
we encountered up in the mountains that terrible
day.
The thin, cold air was laden with screams.
Mine, my friends’, and that...Thing’s.
All that it’d done to us.
All that it was still doing to us.
And never once did it stop shrieking and sobbing
at the top of its lungs, like it wasn’t
even in control of its actions.
It didn’t want to do this.
It just had to.
This violence was as inevitable as the sunset.
I screamed for Kyle.
The snow was coming down thick and fast, a
curtain of burning, brilliant white.
I couldn’t see anyone, not even the thing
that was killing us.
The water in my eyes was starting to freeze
up.
It was cold.
So damn cold.
What the hell was going on here?
Suddenly, a dark shape was moving towards
me through the wall of falling snow.
It was human.
Vaguely.
Moving towards me with frantic speed.
I tensed in anticipation when I then saw Kyle
emerging from the fog.
He was splattered with blood.
His face red from screaming and exertion.
His eyes pleaded for help I couldn’t give
him.
The horror caused my body to react on auto-pilot
with my eyes clamming closed in terror, all
I could do was open my mouth, point with a
shaking, frostbitten finger, and force out
a scream:
“Behind you!”
My words were carried off by the brutal mountain
winds, and with the sounds of mutilation ahead
of me, all I could imagine with eyes clamped
closed as I hit the frozen ground was a long,
grey arm emerging from the flurry behind Kyle,
its gnarled, clawed fingers reaching for his
head...
It was meant to be the vacation of a lifetime.
The kind of thing that you could only experience
once, but you’d never forget.
We all thought, in our own ways, that we’d
look back on the photos with misty eyes when
we were all old men.
We didn’t know that, within a week of arriving
in Switzerland, whether any of us would even
make it to old age would suddenly become an
open question.
All four of us were doctors in training.
Even if you don’t know much about the profession,
it probably won’t surprise you to hear that
there’s a lot of practice and education
involved before you can ever really call yourself
a doctor without feeling like a fraud.
You need to ace your SATs, then slog through
four years of pre-med, another four years
of medical school, then the better part of
a decade doing your residency.
Seems a little much, I know, but believe me,
you don’t want some cowboy sticking his
hands in your chest cavity without all the
proper training.
But after we finally graduated from Harvard
Med, my friends and I decided that we needed
a break before the profession swallowed us
back up again.
It was me, Brandon, Arthur, and of course,
Kyle.
A lot of people I attended class with would
probably make a tidy sum over the course of
their medical careers.
Many of them would have made fine doctors.
But all of us knew that Kyle Molloy was more
than that - He was going to be a truly great
doctor.
He was smart, confident, driven, and had the
kind of smooth, effortless charm that made
you just feel safe around him.
Where he went, we followed.
So naturally, when he suggested we take a
week-long sojourn in Switzerland, the rest
of us were all for it.
We expected an easy week of gourmet cheese,
fine chocolate, and the occasional jaunt down
some old historic districts.
The exact kind of relaxing break we needed
after the soul-crushing pressure of eight
years studying the hallowed art of medicine.
But of course, that wasn’t what Kyle had
planned for us.
It turned out that his tastes were far more
extreme than what the rest of us had in mind.
His vision of a Swiss vacation was mostly
forest hikes, backcountry skiing, snowboarding,
and a little mountaineering through the Swiss
Alps.
Apparently, he’d spent a good portion of
his childhood taking Swiss vacations, and
wanted to give us a little slice of his personal
paradise.
As someone who wasn’t exactly crazy about
heights or the cold, I can’t pretend I was
eager at first.
But Kyle always found a way of talking us
back around.
It wasn’t long until we were booking our
tickets, then sitting on the plane, watching
the mountains get bigger through the porthole,
then our feet were on Swiss soil.
It was a beautiful country, and every bit
as cold as I feared.
But soon enough, the cold would be the absolute
least of our worries.
As I glanced out over the breathtaking view
of the Alps, I had no idea of the terrible
nightmare lurking out there, hidden in the
dark spaces of those great rocks.
Something I learned in med school is that
human beings are kind of like fleshy time
bombs, their fuse ever-burning.
When you reach a certain age - and believe
me, that age is younger than you think - the
assassin that will one day sneak up from within
and take your life is already waiting inside
you.
The cluster of malformed cells that will one
day turn into an inoperable malignant tumor.
The early whispers of the heart defect that
gives your ticker its planned obsolescence.
The microscopic ropes of defective genes that’ll
one day turn into Alzheimer’s or Parkinson’s.
In some cases, it’s just a matter of whether
you can catch it in time.
But in just as many cases, there really is
nothing you can do.
You’re just waiting for it to get you.
After three days in Switzerland, we were suiting
up in our thick coats and climbing boots,
having no idea that the same principle applied
to us.
Except this wasn’t that nasty little assassin
within - it was something outside.
Something that none of our skills or knowledge
could save us from.
Something very old and very dangerous.
We were in fate’s hands now, and sometimes,
fate can be cruel.
Kyle was steaming ahead.
He didn’t just want us to ascend just any
mountain peak, he wanted us to attempt the
Dufourspitze, the highest peak of the Monte
Rosa massif, and the Alps as a whole.
Kyle didn’t think anything less than that
would be a challenge.
After all, this was our once in a lifetime
vacation before we fully started our residency.
Didn’t we want to make this a truly remarkable
experience?
And because it was Kyle, none of us disagreed.
We started at the base of the Monte Rosa and
began to rise.
Its lowest levels barely resembled its frosty
peak, over 4,600 feet above.
We took pictures of some of the wildlife:
The grazing Ibexes, Red Deer, and Chamois.
Arthur had bought a pamphlet on the local
wildlife back at a tourist-friendly mountain
lodge and took great joy in pointing out the
different creatures to us as he saw them.
Brandon got a good laugh about the fact there
was a small bird native to the area known
as the Nuthatch.
Kyle forged ahead, telling tales of his prior
conquests.
The climb gradually transitioned from calm
to grueling as we ascended the mountain.
I could feel the blisters forming on my feet
as the cold first made my face sting, and
then go completely numb.
Arthur, still consulting his pamphlet, expressed
excitement to see a marmot when we finally
reached 2000 feet of elevation.
Brandon started to complain vocally, pouring
himself a cup of coffee from his thermos.
Kyle chastised him for wimping out already.
After all, he said, the hardest parts were
yet to come.
Oh, if only he knew just how right he was...
We ascended further, feeling the air thinning
and our legs growing exhausted beneath us.
I started to resent Kyle as he forged on,
despite it all.
How could he keep going when the rest of us
were faltering?
It just wasn’t fair.
When the rest of us needed to take a breather,
we could feel the sting of his silent judgment.
He was always so damn perfect.
“We’re almost there,” he kept saying,
even though we all knew it wasn’t true.
Things took a turn during one of our rest
stops.
We heard this strange noise, a kind of pained
wailing or keening.
There was nothing overtly menacing about it,
but somehow, just hearing that noise chilled
me deeper than any icy gust of mountain breeze.
It’s difficult to describe, but that terrible
sobbing felt like the purest distillation
of true, bottomless despair.
I’ve never heard a more hopeless and mournful
noise.
Referring to his pamphlet again, Arthur speculated
that the noise could potentially be a Lynx.
Such creatures were apparently native to the
area, and their calls had a quality to them.
But somehow, deep down, I knew this thing
wasn’t human, and it wasn’t an animal
either.
Whatever was making those noises defied normal
metrics of categorization.
To the surprise of no one, me least of all,
Kyle decided to lead the way in the direction
of that awful noise.
Brandon and Arthur followed him closely over
the next tundra, getting closer and closer
to the sobbing.
I hung back a little further, gripped by this
profound sense of dread.
I didn’t want to find out what was making
this noise - I knew, deep in my guts, that
if ever we found out what was making that
noise, something terrible would happen.
And then, moments later, it did.
I heard Kyle gasp, for the first time ever.
The snow was blinding my view, and I couldn’t
make out what was actually happening, until
Arthur ran back toward my direction, and through
the blanket of white snow and with a voice
barely audible through his trembling said
there was a long gray creature.
He said it was naked and looked kind of human
but definitely was not.
He turned back in a panic.
I could barely make out what my buddies were
doing ahead of me, but from the looks of it,
it seemed like Kyle was walking closer.
Every cell in my body was screaming, “No,
no, no!”
But by that point, it was already far too
late for all of us.
The creature began to turn.
Perhaps it was raw animal instinct that saved
me, but I began to turn, too, almost in unison,
to look away from the creature.
I just knew that, whatever this thing was,
I couldn’t bear to see it.
And it was at that moment, as my body hit
the snow and I forced my eyes closed, that
the screaming began.
First, I could recognize the voices of Brandon,
Arthur, and Kyle screaming, and then something
worse.
I can only assume it was the creature itself,
making the most terrible racket.
Shrieking, moaning, sobbing.
And then...Ripping and tearing, blood splattering
across the snow.
I just cowered and shook against the ground
as a massacre unfolded behind me.
I was listening to my friends die, powerless.
Kyle, all his strength and direction stripped
away by terror, was snatched by the creature
as freezing, snowy wind gave it a cloak.
I heard Kyle scream, and then never heard
anything from him ever again.
Soon enough, it was quiet once more.
No noise save for the howling wind and the
quiet sobbing of the abomination from the
snow.
I don’t know for sure why the creature spared
me, but part of me has always suspected that
it was because I never looked at it.
I’ll forever be darkly curious as to what
that monster truly looked like, but my friends
found out, and now I’d never see them again.
I wandered through the unforgiving cold for
hours, fully expecting that my frozen body
would be found in the Alps hours, days, or
even weeks later.
I didn’t even care anymore.
The cold numbed my skin, my limbs, and my
thoughts.
At some point, a helicopter descended onto
the mountainside, full of men in tactical
gear with insignias I couldn’t recognize.
They wrapped me in an emergency blanket and
brought me in, telling me I required treatment.
It all turned to static as we fluttered away
from the mountainside, and all I could think
about was the monster that had taken my friends
from me.
It was still out there, waiting.
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE - Incident 096-1-A
Containment Breach” for more on the Shy
Guy that haunts all of our dreams!